he pointed it up in the air
body camera video shows what led up to
an officer-involved shooting at a
restaurant in Austin Texas
October 23rd on the city's North Side a
9-1-1 call first reported a suspect
later identified as 42 year old Amica
Williams at a nearby apartment complex
police say he walked toward a man there
and pulled out his gun when officers
arrived at the apartment complex they
couldn't find the suspect but minutes
later he was found inside the patio
portion of a restaurant
find another exit we need to try to eat
back with people off the other exit he's
on the patio body camera video shows
officers repeatedly asking Williams to
drop his weapon and come outside
officers can then be heard strategizing
how to get restaurant patrons to safety
worrying the suspect may take some of
them hostage there's got to be a back
door somewhere we just want to find the
bathroom that the people out that are
inside so we can't go in and take it
multiple responding officers surround
the restaurant working to pinpoint
Williams's location and urging him to
come outside
he's right there
security footage from inside the
restaurant shows the suspect grabbing
his weapon officers say Williams then
pointed his weapon in the air after that
shots rang out he pointed it up in the
air
video shows officers rushing toward the
restaurant before a second round of
shots are fired
foreign
as officers approached the patio they
make a plan to secure the area
away it's empty slide back to the rear
all right everybody follow me
everybody's tracking what I'm saying
Williams was shot multiple times he was
treated on the scene for his injuries
and later at a hospital no one else was
injured Williams is charged with
attempted capital murder and deadly
conduct in all five Austin police
officers fired their weapons during the
incident they are all placed on
administrative Duty as the investigation
continues from here a criminal and
administrative investigation into the
shooting are underway for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie